[Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  which means to you know offer my  condolences and you are you mark we went  to school together eight years if you  ever want to catch up if you need a  shoulder to cry on you seriously making  moves on me at my boyfriend's funeral  okay how the hell does someone like mark  like 20 minutes the Golding is such as  yourself could we leave any more on such  as mark money you mean right hi would  you be free to meet up tonight I'm  hoping that one little word yes sugar to  not too much longer than the money's  ours did you reserve the table no I  think be right make it to large Don  there's extra chili extra garlic Oh  [Music]  and as far as it needs to go I don't  think revenge is the answer  my prize at the end of this  I'm not angry then what are you lonely  stay focused  what you're doing is great  [Music]  to you mark whoa we promise to take  Connie Nicholson to be a lawful wedded  wife  [Music]  you